so i think in hollywood it's almost
because i've done this before where i'll
meet an actor yeah and uh it was like i
met a couple actors like okay i was i
belonged i felt like okay i'm part of
this and i had to say something like hey
i i i just said i'm stupid because the
little kid in me comes out i'm realizing
i'm around big stars and i don't feel
like a big star or that or yeah anyway
and i say something and immediately they
look at me like oh you don't belong
you don't fit
see i stopped talking because i know i'm
going to say something incriminating
about like if no like if i'm with
dicaprio right and i go what's up and
he's like how you doing i'm going yeah
i'm all right and he's like so how's the
family i'll suck your dick
[Laughter]
you always suck your dick right now
are you like what what are you talking
about yeah i mean that's i'm so
desperate for like that approval
like oh this guy's weird no no no no no
no no no i would really suck his dick he
chucked the couch
all right i'm sorry don't talk to me
like that you're right i'm sorry
i do
i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't like being
laughed at my face like that you're
[ __ ] bullying me i'm sorry i didn't
beat a bully but here's the here's what
i'm looking for
bobby here's what i'll say though i
don't understand because it wasn't like
dicaprio said suck my dick suck my dick
and you're scared you went up to and go
i'll suck your dick no a fourth line in
how's the family i said pretty good
you know what i mean i'll suck your dick
or whatever you know what i mean it's
not the opening thing would you be
offended because no that's unnecessary
you know not the hey hey
let's not talk about that right stop
stop you don't need to do that yeah stop
hi
hi hi
everybody everybody everybody welcome to
another edition of a tiger
[Music]
yeah
we got
dude i don't know dude we have to start
over now because you're laughing at me
oh don't let me just say something right
now dude this is a holiday i think it's
a holiday edition dude oh yeah i mean
this is about the jesus you're right
you're right so you start over five four
three
five five four four three
two one
[Laughter]
welcome to the tiger belly podcast i'm
your captain bobby lee
so guys um we have a guest i'm gonna i
don't always do this
but i'm gonna say his name
he's gonna say hello and then this is
how it's gonna go
he's gonna say hello
and then because it's jesus's birthday
coming soon to the theater new year
we're gonna i wrote a prayer
and everyone has to repeat when i do
this you repeat the line
and then when i don't do this let me
talk
but and you you and no one's gonna go
this is stupid
we're not doing this anymore you have to
do it
as long as we do the prayer all right
okay
so our guest tonight is jimmy oh yang
give me give him a round of applause is
this why i'm supposed to say hello
i'm nervous now i don't want to yeah
he's sweating say hi now okay hi how are
you i'm good are you a christian uh not
i don't grow up with any religions but
i'm not against anything then there we
go you know because on our podcast we
believe in the lord
no i'm an atheist
she's like a false statement just baby
we have fans from the midwest now in the
south let's just pretend no okay i'm an
atheist but anyway it's jesus's birthday
and i created a prayer
i do love christmas though and so so
when i do this um you guys just repeat
what i say okay okay but i won't just
you know kind of close your eyes right
holding hands or not no we're not going
to hold hands it's weird but it is weird
right
i can't feel it you know what i didn't
think it through
i didn't think
no laughing but i didn't think it
through okay
so um you can open your eyes okay
i feel safer that way yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah good good spitting granola i know i
know i know i know but that's because i
like it when it's on it gives it a
different flavor oh all right so ate it
so um you ready yes yeah dear lord
dear lord let your glory penetrate us
let your glory penetrate within and
without within and without
black cubes and shadows will not curse
the pure hearted
shadows without curse
and we will kill and defeat dark whites
and cleanse the south
dark dark whites
all right
repeat i want to see that line again you
[ __ ] it up sorry we're not suffering
the top no we're going to start from the
top i'm not going to
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a we're
going to do it quicker i don't give a
[ __ ] we're doing it quicker no laughing
do not question it because this is from
the bible okay
oh it's not from a grave of thrones or
anything
serious
you're a guest and i'm going to let you
have that one
okay all right jimmy i'm going to let
you have that one all right because
you're our guest i'm just going to
listen and repeat all right so here we
go dear lord
let your glory penetrate us within and
without that's yours
penetrate us
black cubes and shadows will not curse
the pure-hearted
shadows
and we will kill and defeat dark whites
and cleanse the south and we will kill
and defeat dark whites and cleanse the
south the roads are never ending
[Music]
amen
wow wow so how does that feel jesus was
a you know a creative man thank you you
know you get it yeah i i do now i didn't
i i know i see the light now god damn it
you know what i always knew this about
you jimmy huh that you were like i don't
like the dark whites in the south
he wants to close this out yeah yeah
nobody
what is that supposed to mean
i have to say something right now and i
was gonna save it for another podcast
but i can't
i'm sorry
but
since you're here and gilbert you guys
are here
something happened to me last week
that was very humiliating for me
so i was at the comedy store with nick
youssef
and he goes here i'm gonna i'm gonna go
do a show at the laugh actor can you
drop me off
it's like okay you know what i'm gonna
go eat a green blad so i'll just park
so i park my car and i with nick youssef
and i we walk into the lab factory
and
two people came up to me and goes
where's your ticket
then i go what
yeah you need a ticket or get out
the staff yeah
they go what what they're kids younger i
don't yo don't two people don't feel bad
i saw kat williams get rejected from the
caroline's christmas party and he was in
a full-length fur coat
you're really trying to tell people
yeah yeah and the girl was like what are
you on the list yeah and she's just
brand new these people they they hire
these clubs they don't feel bad that
happened to him at the lab factory too
that's what their point was it happened
to kat but that's not the point no
that's not the point
whatever you're saying right now it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense okay
sorry go all right
is if you're working at a comedy club in
l.a i'm just i'm not okay let me just
say this i know i'm not chris rock
i know i'm not louis ck i know where i'm
at
all right i'm at the bottom fine bobby
lee you were in a wonder girls music
video all right
[ __ ] up all right
but when it comes to the comedy store
and the laugh factor in the improv here
in la
since i've been here for 20 years and
i've played those clubs for 20 years and
i'm friends with the owner of the club
i've been around the country with the
owner of the club i know every single
comic that performs there i'm on the
payroll right that you should don't you
think that they should know who i am or
no yes probably or at least um whoever
you put up to the front to deal with
people coming in the door should at
least be well versed with who's who yeah
so then when it yeah that's part of your
job don't apply for a job at a comedy
club without doing your research to see
who comedians are or at least just
especially the ones who perform at your
club yeah what did you say to them or
who's in the marquee down the street you
know what i mean like it doesn't well i
said it's so embarrassing but then i go
i'm i'm bobby lee
and he goes no i don't what oh god oh my
god they don't even know the name oh my
god
because i've never been in this
situation so you're almost like
you're telling me i'm blushing i'm
sweating
didn't did they recognize nick youssef
no they asked for his uh and he was on
the list
right
yeah he's on the list right so nick goes
um my id i don't i'm performing here
and i'm like i look
comedian
like i couldn't get it out right hey
boss we gotta go with down syndrome
this asian
and then i just kind of left the
building
i just left oh my god and then i told
the doorman who i knew
i go they just asked my days yeah you
know they're new
and i and then i texted everyone i knew
nice i texted crystalia eric griffin um
a bunch of people johnny sanchez
going they wouldn't let me in the laugh
actor
and then i just said i'll never go back
there again
damn over one person's two yes
yes over one person that's the point
okay that's the [ __ ] point of the
whole thing let me say something right
now okay
that's how people learn
okay and also this
the same thing happened to me and i told
you the story about in seattle
oh that's right at the parlor live oh
that have i told that story here on the
podcast you can see it again yeah it's
been a while i'll say the story again
i do a show at the parlor live and i'm
sorry but it's not a big room i sold out
every show
i'm sorry i have to say it
sold out every [ __ ] show
okay
i do one show kill it
go to my hotel room
to take a shower
i go back to the second show
and i walk into the club
and the doorman puts his arm out grabs
me and pulls me out of the club we're
sold out oh my god
right
and i and and every comic that i tell
this dude they said why don't you just
say that you're the headliner
no no no probably doesn't look like that
you shouldn't have to tell them who the
headliner is everybody on staff should
know who the headliner is and you know
what their picture looks like exactly
and also this is also fun for me
so when he puts his arm around me i'm
like this is amazing
you like it because this is about to
turn into something
there's a confrontation that's going to
happen
and i i want to see what i'm going to do
so what i do is i go
i kind of push him aside and i will
continue to walk at the club yeah john
without saying anything was he bigger
than you way bigger he was like this
american indian dude oh they're big he
had long hair right and he as i'm
walking in the club he's now
in front of me
walking backwards
whoa whoa you're
[Music]
then he finally stops me in my tracks
and he goes ow
so i leave
meanwhile i'm supposed to be on stage
and as i'm walking on the club oh yeah
all right fine i'm leaving but tell
ruben cancel the show he goes why
because i'm the headliner
and i just leave
right and didn't do the show no wait
mike no i'm of course going to do the
show
but i'm like milking it right
so i'm walking away and then he's now
looking at like the pictures
he's freaking out no he's like oh my god
that is him or whatever
and he starts getting angry
why didn't you tell me
and i'm screaming back look at the [ __ ]
you know man
right
so then i go up on stage i go back i get
in the club
and then when i get off
it's amazing
there's people in the green room that
i've never seen before
you're talking about the guy that owns
the whole building
you know i mean like like investors you
know i mean they're all there [ __ ] and
they're like all learning we're so sorry
we fire them
and i go no
i feel guilty right
so then i had i spent 24 hours begging
to get that guy's job back are you
serious yeah so it could have been bobby
this is how it works
it could have been as simple as this
i'm the headliner i just walked in and
did my show and nothing we got i had to
do this complete [ __ ] chaos and it's
so fun to do
and i enjoy it
you know i mean so with this laugh
factory thing i'm never going back until
somebody apologizes ah
i don't get it what you don't get it i
mean i do you do get it right you're a
drama queen
that's really weird
no but he really likes he he loves to
make
a bigger fuss about it trust me make a
point
beyond that he wants people to learn a
lesson he loves the drama
it's not drama that's a weird way of
saying it
i enjoy
a
[Music]
um you saw
the coach coach brandt oh that was good
news we saw we so my brother hunted down
connected steve
not only did we hunt him down we went to
the new wrestling facility oh you're
wrestling oh yeah
he gives yeah
he unlocked it he unlocked it for us
because the new coach was in vegas with
it at a tournament yeah yeah so he had
key like we went this is a two million
dollar facility is your name still up
there by the way can i yeah go ahead go
ahead go ahead i know you guys have
talked about how you used to wrestle
poway and stuff yeah steve is a
celebrity there
his name is everywhere his picture
is everywhere up on the walls behind
glass cases on plaques what it's amazing
yeah
is that real
that is real heal steve when you walk i
feel bad for him though cause the window
would wait where were we talking about
where would you do scissors
the way he talked about you it's okay
don't point just slow down wait wait
wait the way he talked about you
degrading disrespectful demoralizing
yeah he talked about you like you're
still in rehab
all right bobby am i lying i got
offended on your behalf right it was the
way the way he talked to me it was
insane all right so let's go
dude oh he said he coulda woulda shoulda
he
he goes
he goes bobby
he said bobby graduated from the school
of what i couldn't show
[Laughter]
all right [ __ ]
enough said dude it's crazy
and you know what's the best part what
we caught on camera so you can re-watch
it
no we have it on camera yeah yeah we
vlogged everything did you explain to
him though just dude he this is what he
said he's like oh what i heard he does
comedy or he's he said it like it was
such a disrespect such a dismissive
thing he was like oh yeah i heard he
didn't he was i guess
he goes i guess he's a comedian or
something now oh oh we talked about it
for like a half hour in his car like
dude isn't that like he was in his own
micro closet like yeah it made me
realize like he that's his world what
was your relationship with him when you
were explain the story ah all right
so in my junior year in high school okay
i went to rehab and went to the mcdonald
center okay
when i got what's so [ __ ] funny dude
keep going no no keep going when i got
out of the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] bro i love it this is good
all right
so my junior year right so my senior
year i'm sober now okay i had through
the summer i'd gone to a bunch of
meetings and and me and my sponsor at
the time
decided because i had to do so many
credits in school to graduate
that he said um my sponsor was just like
you you have to cut weight down to 105
you weigh 125 now damn i don't think
that's a healthy thing i think we should
more focus on the schoolwork maybe take
the year off because you don't really
like wrestling anyway or whatever so
i went to coach brown center i remember
vividly
like a coach
he's like 105 right we're getting ready
and i go i i'm not going to wrestle this
year
and he go he looks at me like this
and that's the last
exchange i've ever had with him oh
you're dead to him
what do you buy
what do you mean bye-bye
[Laughter]
bye-bye bobby i have your back oh you
have my back yeah there's more to life
than wrestling i know not in his eyes
and that's why he's a winner man
[Laughter]
he produces champions
you know who graduated from the school
would have could have showed it with
honors bobby lee
yeah yeah didn't tom delonge graduate
from there oh yeah oh yeah yeah but he
didn't graduate from that school he
wasn't on the wrestling team yeah the
wrestling team was uh it's in a
prestigious
sporting event at our school it's so
nice the newfoundland the new facility
the new facility is like a college
like division one yeah like a real
facility
number one oh they're like nationally
ranked yeah yeah it's crazy they have a
slammers program now for kids
they hooked us up you guys yeah we went
to yeah we got these there because steve
was there he let us have whatever we
wanted he's like oh yeah take whatever
you want
if we would have gone with you yeah i
don't i don't know but yeah you know
you should go
wait hold up should go back yeah but
this is the thing you forgot to mention
that he was mad because he was slated to
wrestle varsity
so that's important you know i was of
course i was going to do a varsity 105
pounder yeah a senior
i know he would you or rather me [ __ ]
do meth and drop the weight and go
[ __ ] wrestle my senior year or did
you would you rather me be sober which
which i did fat and sober fat and sober
dude can i ask you this did that
technically the coach can't say that he
wants one or the other but we know which
one he wanted
he's very very hollywood of him yeah
yeah can i give bobby yeah give it oh i
get one yeah okay my bad
oh can i open it up yeah
no i wanted to say this no no no no what
go ahead call me okay i'm not gonna say
nothing so this is not a birthday thing
or this is no no no no no no no just
opening it up so open it up i will open
it in a second okay
but is this going to hurt me no no
it's not going to rub it this is all
about respect dude
it's out of respect it's not going to be
a shirt that says shoulda couldn't put a
university
[Laughter]
he literally wears medium
oh baby come here give it to me bob do
you want to say a message to the coach
yeah bob give branch to her a message
right now please give him a message dude
you gotta dude tell him your credits man
we need to reconciliate tell them your
movie credits man you gotta let the
world know man go ahead man go ahead man
that brand said or no all right man all
right
i'm okay i'm kind of hurt
all right i'm kind of hurt i think i can
get through it
why are you so why are you acting like
that right it's crazy it's crazy right
but can i i'll be honest with you yeah
it does burn
and i feel it
it burns in my heart damn it's like a
low burn on the bottom half of my heart
and it's probably gonna linger there for
a couple of weeks it breaks okay no
don't put your [ __ ] hand out yeah can
i give you a saving grace can i give you
a safety grace
okay before we left
he said a lot of stuff about you but you
can see
and the scissor bros up
yeah
but one of the things that i did yeah
before we left because i asked him i
said hey do you have any influence on
the high school hall of fame
and he goes i do know some people on the
board he knows the board
so this is what i said
this is what i said don't just hear him
fellow brother i thought of this
wait
let me just get this straight okay
you're going to be on the shoulder
do you want to make me cry right now no
no really yeah because if you tell me
that i'm going to be on the board and
i'm going to be in the hall of fame i
will start to cry right now the scissor
bros are going to make that happen oh
you guys are going to broker that deal
he already emailed him i already emailed
him
a beautiful email with your list of
credits and why you should be considered
yeah we're waiting on a response yeah
this is real this is real though he says
he has influence on the board you are so
funny yeah
and you're going to be in the hall of
fame of poway
where
okay you know here's where i'm not here
please help me baby
where where are you all positive news
is not even on it well forget tom it's
but as we know with everything else it's
all who you know in that in that field
and he has he's a pillar of the
community there and i asked him i was
like
is there any way like
okay yes that being said this is the
closest we've gotten i'm just saying
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen i
have my response to coach branstadter
okay with all the information
okay okay okay think about it think
about please think about it i already
just did no really thinking he tells me
to think about it all the
time it through before you do it all
right now go
okay hold on call him coachy no
voice or reason yeah like high coaching
i'm not gonna call him okay
all right
it's me bob
let me just hurry
dear cochi
it's me bob
hi
pretty good
um i want to say from the bottom of my
heart i'm sorry that
in my senior year
that i chose not to
participate in the wrestling program
i felt like i was focusing on
my sobriety and who i am as a person and
trying to figure out what this whole
thing life is
but in retrospect i do apologize i also
want to thank you for your influence
right because
you're the first man i've
i've seen harry
harry knuckles
he had hairy knuckles
no honestly i remember as a kid you
remember yeah yeah i remember him like
you know because i'd be like on the
bottom like drink couch yeah and you'll
go no you gotta grab the wrist like this
right so you could put his hand on over
the other guy's wrist and i would see
his hairy knuckles
and i would go i remember thinking to
myself i go i've never seen that before
that's cool right so
you're my first harry knuckle experience
right
you're also somebody i was scared of but
i looked up to and i think that you're a
true champion of all time okay and i
also want to say that if you can help me
facilitate this hall of fame situation
right
that my gratitude will go
so deep
towards you and your family
and to your bloodline
right we'll have a framed picture of you
and i would fight for your bloodline wow
right
and um
is that good so love keep going i love
fantastic i love it so love dearly love
right
cochi
i mean heart heart right
and putting quotes
mhm
bobs
little bobs
thank you my mom from the from now on
for the reason you're gonna be good at
me good to me right
that's you you gotta stay i've been good
to you i know you had to feel like you
know everybody said you are the best
sunday ever known really my oh my sister
gets jealous of it see you [ __ ]
in this room you guys think that i'm a
tyrant no he's in that [ __ ] it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he's a [ __ ] head mom
oh my god
i'll buy you a piano okay
yeah get your piano that's it
you're gonna get her a piano yeah of
course
only seven thousand dollars
can we go chat
no never
no i like i love hot top quality you
know that's where you get that from top
quality is that right yeah so
that's
another thing that i get from her which
is everything pick best we want the best
food whatever she thinks the best is
yeah at that time at the time right i
had that same thing which is weird
you know he
last month he came on right because of
his daddy he bought her shoes
you know uh it's a green shoes oh no no
you know so i brought with me
when i brought my husband remains
so i gave it to him he said mom i'm not
gonna wear
then why did he buy
you know i think he pays so much money
you know so she saw you know over there
yeah yeah where is it i he she gave it
to me the blue conversation oh i
know i got that from you never rude uh
weird [ __ ] i know but then my brother
got um
my dad yeah
yeah
right he's quiet sometimes serious
temper yeah but that
innocent [ __ ] that he does you know that
kid thing that he does i think he gets
that from you digging from nose